I consider it necessary to support the
proposal of the Ministry of Defense and the
General Staff to conduct partial mobilization in the
Russian Federation;
I repeat, we are talking about partial
mobilization, that is,
only citizens
who are currently in the
reserve and, above all, those who
served in the ranks of the armed forces, will be subject to military service  forces has
certain military
specialties and relevant experience
called up for military service before
being sent to the unit, you will without
fail undergo additional
military training, taking into account the experience of a
special military operation, a
decree on partial mobilization was signed
in its aggressive anti-Russian
policy The West has crossed every line, we
constantly hear  threats against our
country, our people, some
irresponsible politicians in the West not
only talk about plans to organize the
supply of long-range
offensive weapons to Ukraine, systems that
will allow strikes on Crimea to other  In many
regions of Russia, such terrorist
strikes, including with the use of
Western weapons, are already being inflicted on the
border settlements of the
Belgorod Kursk Region.
Nuclear blackmail has
begun  and the admissibility of the use of
weapons of mass destruction of nuclear weapons against Russia by
those who allow themselves such statements
against Russia, I want to remind you that our
country also has various
means of destruction A for individual
components and more modern than those
eliminated and with a threat to the territorial
integrity of our country to protect
Russia of our people  we will certainly
use all the means at our
disposal
this is not a bluff
and those who are trying to blackmail us with
nuclear weapons should know that the
wind rose can unfold in their st  defense,
we cannot, we have no moral
right to give people close to us to be
torn apart by the executioner, we cannot but
respond to their sincere desire to
determine their own lives, the
parliaments of the people's republics of Donbass, as
well as the military-civilian administrations of the
Kherson and Zaporozhye regions
, decided to hold
referendums on the future of these  territories
did not turn to us to Russia with a request to
support such a step, we will do everything
to provide safe conditions for
holding referendums so that
people can express their will and the
decision about their future that the
majority of residents of the Donetsk and Lugansk
People's Republics of Zaporozhye and
Kherson regions will take  support for a long
time we haven’t talked about it, I can’t help but talk about
our losses. Lost
today, 5937 people who died
300 thousand reservists who will be
called up, I want to say right away that this is not a
one-time job, this is the work that will be
carried out according to plan, as I already said